hunter biden's uh laptop is back in the
news yeah okay
big deal how are we gonna talk about
that this is a big deal
okay does anybody know exactly why it's
back in the news
apparently the new york times clarified
that the laptop was in fact hunter
biden's actual laptop whoa they got left
at a delaware repair exactly because
initially
mainstream media and this is even
right-wing media i think fox also shut
it down everybody came down they said
this is most likely misinformation maybe
russian misinformation
trying to sway the election but now it
turns out
that it was actually real yeah
and maybe
being used to sway the election in
biden's favor by silencing the story
yeah whoa yeah but i didn't really
understand what was on the laptop that
was such a big deal just him being the
man yeah i know he's smoking crack and
smoking out thoughts yeah why is it
handsome
no but i think it was basically like
biden biden was doing what any father
would do which is try to get his fuck-up
son a job yeah using his influence which
i love good but here's the thing if you
get caught
you get caught yeah and then you got to
get punished but before you get caught
that's what every single dad would do
100 i'mma do it y'all are going to do it
yeah every single one has an indian way
of life nepotism
yeah that's what we do yeah is it yeah
why what's so indian about nepotism veer
was talking about it remember it needs
to just have like a family business
that's just what it is
yes yes yeah yeah yeah he thought that
they invented family business
yeah in fact this is this you know that
was saying oh the family business yeah
like you know how you know now but
there's literally like sometimes your
last name is like merchant and that's
just the family business
like it's that's what you do
yeah
guys last name is doctor
indian dude
an engineer
no it's not an indian thing i know he's
an engineer hold on one second
did dove just jihad this podcast i know
what the [ __ ] is
looking at me like i was supposed to
acknowledge them
[Laughter]
so what do you do is bad i guess there
were some like uh business dealings
between um ukraine and there was like
gifts like china and ukraine or whatever
and of course this was gonna happen they
want to they want to get i don't want to
use curry favor again but they want to
like curry favor with the president and
so they basically like are looking after
the president's kid and you basically
get to the president through the
president's kid but didn't the [ __ ]
clintons do this for years like didn't
they have the clinton foundation yeah
and that's how you would there these
other countries would donate money to
the clinton foundation and that would be
funneled back to the clintons and then
ideally you know you would use that to
have some sort of like influence i have
the president's ear or something like
that 100 percent right this is what
every politician does look up your kids
republicans do that and you get
kickbacks that's the whole point of
being a politician you think any of
these guys are straight george bush went
to yale yeah
yeah
this is what you're supposed to do take
care of your kids but if you get caught
you should get slapped on the wrist and
it shouldn't go away but when you're the
president you can make sure go away
this is probably he wasn't president yet
technically
he was vice and he was going to be the
president but yeah he has people in uh
places of power like i do think it's
weird that like social media
specifically like if a company doesn't
want to run the story whatever but the
fact that like twitter was like you
can't talk about the story for like 14
days or whatever i do think that's
[ __ ] up like it's intentionally
suppressing something that you don't
know if it's true or not oh wait is that
what they said i don't know i'm pretty
sure yeah twitter like so that you can't
talk about the story until after the
election it was like it was censored
until we can verify if it's true or not
that's what i understand that might be
incorrect but that's the way i
understood it which i thought that was
[ __ ] up but i'm also like what's on
the laptop is so damn it also what broke
[ __ ] fixes their laptop
yeah what was that buy a laptop
on it for crack maybe yeah i mean
if you had some like fire home movies on
there that he ain't back up in the
icloud he's like nah i'm gonna need that
but like i mean this kid is monumentally
stupid yeah like you are monumentally
stupid you think what you will about joe
biden now in his day that was a bad
[ __ ] he was a voice a politician
yes have you seen the picture of him as
a kid stubborn no he was hot yeah i had
to show you watch this all right honey
look great for a crackhead let's be
honest
are you judging crackhead if there's a
crackhead beauty contest male or female
bro
no this is joe we're talking about joe
yeah but i'm saying he got good genes
now he's looking like matt pavich this
guy's he's a peace
absolute stunt
okay so then what's the big deal they
suppress this information he'll bide him
win the election oh yeah who gives a
[ __ ] it's always something with these
hillary's emails and trump and russia
and the laptop i don't give a [ __ ] man i
don't think it works the outcome that
much you don't think so yeah i don't
think so
oh no the president's son
like i don't like that they
intentionally suppressed information i
think that's [ __ ] up they're censoring
[ __ ] that you don't know or not like
they're calling misinformation when it
wasn't verified to be misinformation but
like i don't think it's that big of a
thing now
that they're like oh it's whatever like
even tucker had like a bombshell report
remember this he was like we have
bombshell information about uh you know
hunter biden and joe biden blah blah and
then he got lost in the mail
do you remember this
he had this whole thing where he's like
it's going to come out like wait till
you guys hear this and he's like turns
out i got lost
uh this is like when maddow had trump's
tax returns and [ __ ] nothing yeah
it's just like look at this guy
like political theater [ __ ] and it's
like all right
like is this doing anything or is it
just like a pointless story for fodder
that's why i liked what npr said
i think when the story is
but like when the story came out they
said we're not going to cover it because
it's a pointless distraction it's
unimportant and i was like at least
they're acknowledging like you know this
is we don't think aren't we kids
yeah but like they go we don't think our
viewers care about this and in order to
pander to our viewership we're just not
going to report on [ __ ] that they don't
care about and now we're telling you
they're just like very honest but that's
different than not important
we don't think that this will get
ratings yeah exactly it's not important
for our audience yeah our audience
doesn't want to even know these did they
still want us is that important for our
audience no but like that was the
implication
at least that's the way i read it that
they're just like our le our liberal
left-leaning audience doesn't care about
this so but they don't want to know but
when they should care the most because
those are going to be the people that
are actually voting for this guy and to
act like
i mean right now we're literally in a
war right like russia and ukraine are in
a war yeah and russia is alleging that
there's too much western influence in
ukraine and that's part of the
justification for that war yeah and now
we're seeing western influence in
ukraine so to act like this doesn't play
a little bit of a part in it yeah yeah
that's the part that i don't understand
like his dealings with ukraine is that
influencing what's happening now i don't
know this is what i keep reading and
people are saying oh yeah zelinski's a
western puppet let's start the other and
it's like okay well then who made sure
zolinsky is in there i mean who was in
who was in charge or who was in office
during that time was it like this
connection
so like this connection is the first
seed because this in and of itself
doesn't mean you're gonna treat ukraine
differently but it's like the first sign
that maybe there's a bunch of things
we're doing with you
maybe we have a little bit more
influence in there than we would like to
believe maybe they're not a completely
autonomous nation maybe they're not
making up all their making all their
decisions by themselves maybe they're
being influenced by us and maybe they're
i love that i love that we're
influencing them yes i think that's
great okay what is this idea that they
need to be autonomous yeah we're the
[ __ ] united states of america
there's an empire we run [ __ ] [ __ ] runs
through us unless you're saudi arabia
and you need to get your ass taken care
of as well well if if that's
true savages
if that's true
you've seen the way they treat women
over there
if that's true
yeah they're not civilized like us
that's true
then we would have to do something
to saudi arabia no
so if
if the united states is the one that
propped up zelinski if we were the one
controlling
their i don't know controlling but
influencing their government
and all of a sudden they're at war with
russia because of policies that we want
to place in the ukraine well shouldn't
we have their back no um
shouldn't we what is this depends on how
much influence like if we literally
place the president there i mean that's
the thing like
if did we place him there is he
following every single thing we say like
we don't know how much
influence we do have right and
yeah
yeah
we
they got to be part of nato bro
it's just it is what's nato
it's allies
it's it's not going to happen sweden's
not even in nato nobody knows what any
of these things are sweden mad [ __ ]
they don't need to be part of nato [ __ ]
sweetheart hey hey hey [ __ ]
i'm not even look i don't know nothing
but i'll tell you this i know this much
it's us against china at some point in
the near future
this is we're all playing that game
until we get to india yeah sweetie could
get it too he's from india yeah
andy you better choose up too you chose
to choose up all right they got a
[ __ ]
figure it out
figure it out
tell them yo figure it out figure you
want to say you message me
you're a [ __ ] russian favorite [ __ ]
that [ __ ] yeah we need their oil for
what we drive [ __ ] rickshaws
everywhere
hell yeah israel too oh yeah zelinski
hit up israel they were like yeah they
got to work with the weapons yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah at least you guys don't
really do that much for india but israel
y'all only hear ben shapiro found a way
to blame it on obama
this guy's unbelievable that's
impressive this
oh the reason why it's really thomas's
fault israel
tomorrow will be a reason why it's
ladies obviously but he's like oh the
reason why uh israel has to keep
diplomatic relations with russia and
ukraine is because of the obama's
failings in syria and canning over syria
to iran and russia so iran and russia
are in israel's backyard so if they
don't uh so so if they don't appease
both of them then it could be horrible
for israel so really it's obama's fault
oh my god it is
second it is
the point making is obama's fault
i mean there you go half a million
series
whose fault is it that yala in israel
half a million whose fault is that we
were that y'all got a country
uk
united uk
wow they really believed that wow about
uk swung there
yeah
united states said nah [ __ ] that you
think it would have happened obama's
good at basketball okay he doesn't do
anything wrong yeah
he's out
yeah
yeah can you dunk why is bashar al-assad
still alive guys name one jew who could
dunk oh marie caspi homie can't do he's
iranian that [ __ ] dunk israeli
he's a three-point shooter he's he could
dunk him
you can dunk
okay back to the point
okay go uh okay two jews who could dunk
[Applause]